Welcome back to Drew's News.
We have a a legend at the desk.
She's a writer with many best selling titles under her belt.
A little book called Sex In The City
launched one of the biggest cultural
phenomenons of our time.
Please welcome Candice Bushnell.
I am so thrilled to be here
because we saw each other at a fashion show.
And I said Candice.
You said come on the show,
and I said, I'd love to,
and you made it happen.
Girl, you've got the power.
Well,
unlike Mark Cuban,
who I shyly did not approach,
we were luckily enough to get to converse
and I mean, I'm such a fan,
and an admirer of Sex In The City,
and I'm curious where your book ends
and the series continues to go on,
what is your feelings and opinions of everything?
I mean, you literally launched a cultural phenomenon!
Well actually, it's been amazing,
and it's amazing that the show has lasted for so long
and so many iterations,
but at the same time,
Sex In The City is actually a small part of my career
and I've written several best selling books
and I've had two other TV shows,
LipStick Jungle and The Carrie Diaries.
I love both!
Love,
and my new book and my new stage show
which I wrote and performed in called
Is There Still Sex in the City
is really about an exploration of
the Sex In The City woman, in her 50's and 60's.
So that's something that I'm going to continue with that
and try to turn that into a TV series.
One thing that I do love is again relationships
and being the queen of New York dating and columns
and everything that you are and do,
I was wondering if you want to head to
the dating headlines with us.
I absolutely would.
Okay, let's take it away.
First headline.
Wear my glasses.
Okay, there's so many new dating terms,
it's hard to keep track.
Now Elite Daily reports
that there's a word for when
you get all dressed up, hair done, makeup ready,
dressed to the nines only to have your date text and cancel.
It's called glam-boozled
and a dating survey says that 58% of daters
say they've been glam-boozled.
A good rule of thumb is if you haven't heard from him
an hour before the date, hold off on those lashes.
Now the question is,
have either one of you been glam-boozled,
or have you been the glam-boozler?
Try it.
You try to glam-boozle me,
you better show up with a receipt,
a doctor's note or a neck brace.
I'm sorry.
Not happening.
You don't get a date number two.
How many people in the audience have been glam-boozled?
Not that many of us.
Either we're not being honest
or there's a very lucky audience here.
Okay, who has glam-boozled?
No one's gonna admit.
Did somebody admit that?
Yes, you did!
I love it.
You have a microphone and a camera coming to you.
Aren't you so glad you raised your hand, sir?
Why did you glam-boozle someone?
I got nervous and scared.
We've all done it.
You're all liars.
How interesting that is,
because you got nervous and scared.
See, it wasn't even about the other person.
And that's why someone's gonna take that
and be like, what's wrong with me?
That's what I did.
Someone stood me up
and I thought God, did they hear something about me
and I went through this whole laundry list
and I just thought, you know what?
No, they don't know me.
They don't know anything about me,
and this is on them,
and I just need to carry on with my afternoon
and not make this a reason to self loathe.
Forget it.
Buh bye.
What about this, you guys.
Vogue is asking this important question.
What do you call the person
that you've just started dating?
When Carrie dated the Russian on Sex In The City,
remember she said, I've taken a lover.
You remember that?
Lover.
Yes,
but that quote doesn't work for everybody,
because if you just say it's the person I'm dating,
that can feel clunky, right?
So Vogue suggests some other options.
They call them your flame, your extended fling,
your suitor, your crush.
God, I don't like any of these.
I feel like.
I say my future ex husband.
That's good!
Problem solved, right.
I think though if you're starting to call
who you're just seeing, something,
they're gonna stop calling you back,
because that just seems like too much pressure.
No?
Yes.
Well for me, the word lover,
that is a strange thing,
for me to call somebody,
because it feels like it's French.
Nothing against French people
and also something that when you're married
you have lovers.
I always think of French married people having lovers.
Oh, like a mistress.
Like you're a cuckold.
An adulterer.
Yes, exactly.
Well, I would say,
I would just call it yay.
That would be my term.
Well thank you Candice Bushnell.
I am so glad that you had come by the desk
and come and do this with us.
Now Candice is taking her one woman show
Is There Still Sex In The City
out on the road later this year,
so make sure to look out for that
and don't get glam-boozled or don't glam-boozle
and let's all be good to each other
and we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)